do you have a hard time getting people
in higher positions
to read your screenplays oh god yes it's
like it's the big catch-22 that is one
of those
like the conceptions that were true uh
absolutely is the catch-22
issue because people producers don't
want to read your work unless it's
coming to them from someone they trust
so if you don't have an agent you're
probably not going to get read by
netflix
in fact with netflix you won't even get
ready you don't have a show runner lined
up already even
um they because
there are so many people writing scripts
that first of all most of the scripts
coming in are going to be from amateur
writers and so they can't read all these
thousands i think there's something
like uh was it 10 000 scripts get
registered with wga every year
that's not even counting like going to
copyright you know so that's a lot of
material coming in
and most of it is coming from amateurs
when you think there's only like 4 000
people in the wga
um so they're not going to want to sit
there and spend all their time doing
that so they're only going to read
vetted material and the ways to vet
someone is having it come in through an
agent
although that's different now with the
the strike stuff going on you know with
the wj versus the agencies
um or a manager that they trust or
another producer
that they know who maybe has read it you
know and is like oh this isn't for us
but it might be for you sort of thing
or if they have a personal connection
with you which is where the whole
networking thing comes in
um and if it's not coming from one of
those vetted
avenues or a screenplay contest if you
want a script contest then they'll
probably want to read it
but unless there's a way they can vet it
you're a nobody to them
and they don't want to read 10 000
nobody scripts
if they have this pile of like 10 that
they trust
and how did you get your agent i got i
don't have an agent i have a manager oh
i'm sorry
and she kind of came to me again it was
through twitter that she found me
that's great uh last year um during
staffing season they had the wga
staffing boost
tag you know the hashtag wga staffing
boost and i had posted
something on on there that um
latoya morgan who had started it
like retweeted and that was where all i
saw like all these followers coming from
and then my manager happened to see
the two and was like well what kind of
stuff do you have and so i
pitched a couple things she looked me up
on indb and was like okay send me this
and this and she loved my stuff so
she's repping me and um sending my stuff
out there like i said
i got her at the very end of staffing
season last last year so it was about
time
i was even rep for her to start singing
stuff out like almost every show was
already
fully staffed so i couldn't really get
any meetings last year but fingers
across for this season i know i'm
they're they're still shooting pilots
um so a lot of things that are fully
staffed now are stuff that went straight
to series already but the things that
just got pilot orders
uh they won't be doing staffing for
another like three to
two to five weeks basically you know
like beginning of march they'll start
probably um so fingers are still crossed
i know there's at least
three shows that i'm on a read list for
right now that
hoping that goes well but yeah so my
manager kind of just came to me
based on a tweet that's really cool yeah
especially after years of sending stuff
out to reps and
either them not connecting with the
material
or them meeting with me and we just
decided it wasn't a good fit
you know based on what they want to do
and what i want i want to do and that
sort of thing so
um it definitely felt like a bizarre
turn of events to go from me doing all
this work of like
querying everybody and not really
getting anywhere with it to be like
here's a tweet about who i am and what i
write and then a manager coming to me
being like that sounds great let me read
you
you know so do you think you were just
ready though
would you have been ready two years
earlier i feel like i've been ready for
years
um maybe not for television as much
uh like i moved out here because i
wanted to work on tv my experience
before i moved out here was
like i had written a couple of specs for
existing shows to enter into the into
the
different fellowships and then i got
hired to write the eight episodes of
that british
sci-fi series that again still hasn't
even picked up
um but i feel like i'm more
ready now to deal with people than i
would have been when i first moved out
here
having not known what to expect because
again when i was in virginia all my
communication was either on the phone or
via email
and now that i'm here i need meetings
it's all about the meetings
so i don't think i would have been able
to handle a meeting when i first moved
out here as was proof like i said my
first meeting two days after i got here
was not good so now that i've met with a
bunch of people
and i've done the networking thing and
i've done talking and now i actually
know some people in the industry that i
didn't know when i moved out here
um maybe i'm in a slightly better
position for her to actually do
something
with with me you know i feel like though
people
in whatever pursuit they have out here
they need those like
couple bad experiences sure to kind of
like earn their stripes a little bit
and you know you don't really know
necessarily how it all works
until you're in there you know you can
read all the book you can read this book
you can read
available on amazon um you can read all
the books you can read all the articles
that come through you can watch
all of the videos uh but until you're
actually
doing it yourself all you have is theory
you know it's kind of
doing it's like doing physics without
ever doing physics sort of thing you
know i can read you
a textbook it doesn't mean you have any
idea what it all said until you sit down
and do an experiment you know
um so yeah those bad experiences are
what helps you move along to even
understand how the industry works
right and i think it it's good to get
knocked down a couple times because then
it just it's just there's something that
kind of fortifies you a little bit and
so when you actually have a good
experience
i don't know if you go as high because
you kind of know like it keeps you a
little more level-headed i think
um i was trying to think of a great
quote it just
fell out of my head um
but it's one of those things where you
you you don't know what you
have until you've lost it sort of thing
okay
so i feel like it's almost like a
reverse of that you don't know where you
can go until you've already like
seen the bad stuff like you don't know
how success is going to look so you've
seen how failure looks you know that's
true
i like that it's good you've mentioned
reading list a couple times
can you tell us what reading list sure
so like for the shows
um it's mainly a tv thing um
you know the show runner will get a
stack of scripts that they need to go
through so they can try and pick who
they want to hire for their
their show um so i've gotten a couple of
my scripts
on that stack but it just hasn't you
know like i said when
last year it was at the very end of the
season so it was like they only had like
one spot left to fill by that point
and they still have a stack of scripts
there so but you can't even get on that
stack of scripts without the
representative
to like either manager an agent you know
pitching your stuff over there
you can do a little bit more with
twitter now because after the whole
thing last year
when the wga and the agents clashed
uh a lot of show runners like latoya
morgan and some others
liz alper um javier what's javi's last
name
i'm drawing a blank on hobby's last name
but like these big show runners
that are like okay well we're not
dealing with agents anymore so
writers who should we be looking at and
that's where the wga
staffing boost came in of writers who
are reading other people and be like oh
this person has this spec that's amazing
you need to check it out they would be
great in your room
before that it was agent or nothing
basically agent or manager or nothing
like
so you can't even get on this on the
list
i got myself on a couple of read lists
using the wga staffing thing
um those shows end up not getting picked
up so i didn't even need to really meet
with
the writers but it was like writers who
had a show that was really cool to me i
loved the pilot when i read it
and they're like yeah if this had picked
up i'll i'll take a look at your stuff
you know that would have
would have never happened before the
whole mess with the wga and the agencies
last year
um so yeah that's what the list the
reading lists are is is the list of
scripts that the uh the shareholders
are supposed to go through and and it's
again if they don't have to go through
the whole stack they're not gonna
so if you're coming in there from a rep
that they trust or if another reader
they that they know
suggested you you're going to get read
before the ones that are just you know
randomly submitted to them
you